Since the bus travels 10 miles per hour slower than the van, we can use x minus
10 for the bus's rate. We know the bus can travel 200 miles, so that distance
is 200. Our van on the other hand travels 240 miles in that same amount of
time, and if we remember from before. We know distance equals rate times time.
So we know time is equal to the distance divided by the rate. So to find the
amount of time it takes the bus to travel 200 miles, we takes 200 and we divide
it by the rate, x minus 10. This is our expression for time. And for the van,
we take its distance, 240, and we divide it by its rate which is x. And here's
our complete table. Great work if you found most of these answers. Even more
amazing if you got them all correct, even if it wasn't your first try.